herr bergmann die jugendämter die
reagieren zu spät sie hätten
beispielsweise in diesem fall den
kontakt verbieten müssen sie hätten
vielleicht auch das spätere opfer aus
der familie nehmen müssen das ist so das
allgemeine urteil was man hört wenn
solche fälle ans licht kommen
was meinen sieger zu reagieren
jugendämter zu spät und falsch hinter
reagieren häufig spät das ist richtig
richtig
nach unseren erfahrungen als anwälte hat
man jedoch dass weiter verbreitete
problem dass die jungen dazu früh
reagieren und hier in der münsteraner
fallenden ich ja nicht kenne kann ich
auch nicht beurteilen da scheint es so
zu sein dass man sich alle mühe gegeben
hat das richtige zu tun man hat die alle
experten zusammen genommen
aber man hat keine anhaltspunkte gab
dabei muss man berücksichtigen dass die
familie ein hohes gutes durch das
grundgesetz geschützt und geschützt
nicht nur durchs rund gesetz auch durch
die menschenrechtskonvention geschützt
und da kann man nicht einfach so
eingreifen da müssen gravierende gründe
seien
und das scheint so zu sein dass man bei
dem jugendamt in münster da trotz
intensivster erforschung keine
hinreichenden gründe gesehen hat aber
wir an das problem häufig in unserer
praxis dass die jugendämter ein problem
haben und das problem sich da nur vom
hals schaffen dass sie kinder aus den
familien herausnehmen großes
also in dem fall hat das jugendamt das
richtige tun wollen es war dann doch
aber das falsche wie sich rückblickend
jetzt herausstellte bringt es vielleicht
etwas dann an den strukturen zu
schrauben also wenn jugendämter nicht in
der lage sind objektiv das richtige zu
tun bräuchte er es vielleicht so etwas
wie eine kontrollinstanz die noch mal
auf die ergebnisse die entscheidung des
jugendamtes schaut oder nicht es wird ja
häufig und schon ganz lange als ich bin
seit über 20 jahren dabei das fordern
gefordert dass es so was wie ein ober
jugendamt gibt dass die entscheidung des
jugendamtes überprüft dabei muss man
allerdings berücksichtigen dass die
entscheidung wie die in münster ja nicht
ohne weiteres zu überprüfen sind sondern
hier hätte auch meinetwegen 1 1 oder
jugendamt oder die neue kompetenz für
ein landesjugendamt hätte nichts an den
tatsachen geändert weil man halt eben
nicht mehr hatte sie sehen ja dass der
jetta hier sehr professionell seine
sachen verheimlicht hat aber
grundsätzlich ist es so wenn leute mit
dem jugendamt in berührung kommen die
kinder raus nehmen wollen
da müsste es möglich sein dass die
behördenintern oder jedenfalls durch
einen anderen zug in der behörde
da zu einer überprüfung kommt
überprüfung ist jetzt beim
familiengericht nur damit wird häufig
den leuten gedroht wir erleben dass
immer wieder fast täglich in unserer
praxis dass gesagt wird also wenn ihr
jetzt nicht zustimmt eine herausnahme
des kindes dann gehen wir vor gericht
und davor haben viele leute angst und
man ist wirklich den satz
den habe ich als richter nie gebraucht
aber ich brauche ihn jetzt ganz bewusst
vor gericht und auf hoher see ist man in
gottes hand
in der familie gerichtsbarkeit haben wir
das problem dass es keine ausgebildeten
richter gibt es gibt weder in dem
studium noch in der referendarausbildung
noch sonst eine ausbildung im
familienrecht
man wird einfach familienrichter ich war
zum beispiel im baurecht dabei und wurde
von einer familie rechneten die ahnung
dass und damit sprechen sie ja ein
weiteres problem an wenn wir weggehen
von den jugendämtern hinzu
den verhängten strafen am amtsgericht
erscheinen in der öffentlichkeit als zu
gering jetzt wird wieder geforderte
strafmass hoch setzen wird denn aber das
vorhandene strafmaß überhaupt im moment
ausgeschöpft
ja ich halte nichts von dieser
diskussion des strafmaß hochzusetzen
kein täter lässt sich abschrecken durch
ein hohes strafmaß
sonst würden keine morde geschehen
sondern die gerichte müssten die strafen
das vorhandene strafmaß wirklich
ausschöpfen
und wenn bei einem fall wo jemand was
weiß ich 30 tausend kinderpornografische
bilder betroffener rechner hat wenn man
wenn der mit 13 monaten 14 monaten
freiheitsstrafe auf bewährung und 3000
euro geldbuße davon kommt dann bin ich
damit nicht zufrieden
nicht das müsste häufiger sein und wenn
man gegen eigentum verstößt dann
schlagen die gerichte richtig zu aber
bei diesen fällen gibt es eher milde
ich habe einen fall erlebt wo eine
mutter sechs jahre ihren sohn
missbraucht hat und das verfahren wurde
wegen geringer schuld eingestellt ich
finde sowas kann erlöst